HUSAIN BENGALI: Let's talk
about reducing the load
time of your website
and mobile apps
through better
image compression.
WebP is an image
format that delivers
significantly smaller file sizes
than traditional image formats.
I'm Husain, the product
manager for WebP,
and I'm here to tell you
about the format and some
of the recent improvements
we've delivered.
Over the past year, the
biggest feature we added
was support for animated images.
Now you can create
high-quality animations
with rich colors
and transparencies,
all while getting much
better compression than GIF.
With this addition,
WebP now supports
the use cases of all major
traditional formats--
JPEG, PNG, and GIF.
WebP is already in use across
a number of major websites.
If you use Chrome or Opera to
access YouTube or Google Play,
you've already been experiencing
the benefits of WebP.
When Google Play added
support for WebP,
the footprint of image
file sizes transferred
to Chrome and Opera users
dropped by a whole 35%.
On YouTube, an increasing
number of video thumbnails
are being served in WebP format,
leading to 10% faster page
loads.
With over one billion users
visiting YouTube every month,
the aggregate time saved
by faster loading images
will be about 140,000
hours each day
once this rollout is complete.
So you might be wondering, how
can I get started with WebP.
The good news is
getting WebP integrated
into your app or
website is easy.
You can start by
downloading the WebP
library from the URL shown here.
The included cwebp
tool will allow
you to convert your
images to the format.
Note that since not all
browsers support WebP yet,
you will need to fall back
to the original image format
when serving to
incompatible browsers.
WebP is so powerful that many
major CDNs have implemented it
on their side.
That is, the CDN will be able
to transcode your images to WebP
and serve them to compatible
clients on your behalf.
So check with your provider,
because they may already
be able to do much of the
heavy lifting for you.
If you don't use a CDN,
consider the paid speed service
which, amongst many
other optimizations,
will automatically
transcode and serve
WebP images to
compatible browsers.
If you're the developer
of a mobile app that
has significant image
content, you too
can take advantage of
the benefits of WebP.
Android versions 4.0 and
above natively support lossy
WebP D code, and full support
across all Android versions
can be assured by packaging the
WebP D code libs into your app.
Similarly on iOS, just
package the D code libraries
as part of your app.
And you'll be able to
serve the same content
to apps on both platforms.
Major native apps such as
Google+ and Facebook for both
Android and iOS already use
WebP for faster-loading images
and lower bandwidth consumption.
Google+ alone saves over 50
terabytes of bandwidth every
day as a result of serving
WebP to its mobile apps.
To learn more about WebP,
visit our developers site.
Faster-loading images might
be less work than you think.